Epona is pretty much the most famous  video game horse ever but will she be in  breadth of the wild I'm Tony and this is  your untamed gamespot news update Zelda  master I egl new mom mentioned Epona  last month saying he didn't want to  reveal quote how to find her game  informer's knew his cover story expands  on this claiming that Epona doesn't join  link in the game so maybe she is there  but can't be ridden in any case breath  of the wild is full of horses you can  tame and name yourself so potentially  you could keep a whole stable of Epona's  if you want to breath of the wild  launches for nintendo switch and wii u  on March third that also happens to be  the switches launch day so keep an eye  on gamespot for plenty more coverage on  nintendo's new hybrid console and to  keep up with all the latest selva news  be sure to hit that subscribe button  you